Then Imam al-Ghazali shares with us various narrations and stories of the pious predecessors.
Wa Dhul-Qarnain who met an angel
Dhul-Qarnain whose story is mentioned in Surat al-Kahf
he once met one of the angels and he said teach me something
that will increase my faith and certitude.
And the angel said to him, "Do not become angry
because
the shaytan
has a greater capability
of controlling the human being when he becomes angered.
So, respond to anger with by suppressing it.
And calm the fire of anger
with uh a ta'wuda which is uh being
the opposite of rushing and being rushed which is deliberation.
And calm the fire of anger with deliberation.
You know, a lot of times especially when you're young and especially in today's world there's
so much going on and with social media you have to have an opinion about everything.
Everybody is a a commentator and an expert on everything that happens in the world.
And then particularly people will want to know, you know, "What what what do What does
Islam have to say about this?"
Often times when things are going on in the world there's current events and things that
are taking place that are very hot topics.
The best response is to slow down.
To really think about it.
Everyone wants to be smart.
Oh, I've got it figured out and I can be the the religious and social commentator
on this.
But you might say things that you'll regret later.
A lot of times just let me think about it.
A man once asked Imam al-Shafi'i Allah a question and Imam Shafi'i was quiet.
The man asked again.
And Imam al-Shafi'i said, "Hold on.
I'm still thinking about whether answering your question or remaining quiet is more beloved to Allah.
I'm still working on that piece.
You know, a man a man came to Imam Malik and asked him all of these
questions. I don't know.
I don't know. I don't know.
And then he answered a few questions.
He said, "Man, you don't know?
You're Imam Malik. Everybody says you know everything."
Imam Malik said, "Go out and tell people I don't know anything.
It's okay. I'm not here to entertain you.
This is This is knowledge of revelation.
I can't make it up.
If I don't know, I have to say I don't know.
I have to think about it.
I have to research.
We have to contemplate, consult.
All of these things are so important.
And mashallah it's really
very encouraging to see so many young people in the room.
This is a skill the sooner you you learn it the better.
Consult people.
Think deeply about things.
Often times your passion is a strength
but allow that passion and that strength to be guided by deliberation and and seeking advice
from people more experienced and wiser than yourself.
Don't be someone who's reactionary.
There's a difference between taking initiative and being reactionary.
Anger is a very reactionary response.
So, here the angel is telling Dhul-Qarnain
calm your anger with deliberation.
Wa iyyaka wal 'ajalah and beware
of haste.
Rushing.
Got to do it now.
Jazakallahu khairan.
Fa innaka idha 'ajilta akhta'ta hazzak because if you're hasty you'll make a mistake.
You'll make a mistake.
Wa kun sahlan layyinan lil-qaribi wal-ba'id and be easygoing and gentle with people who are close
to you and people who are not close to you.
Wa la takun jabbaran 'anida and do not be a
tyrannical person. Someone who is stubborn and obstinate and difficult to be with and who is
harsh with others.